[ __ ]
[Music]
well a leader will be speaking yes a
leader will be speaking he's our
surprise surprise surprise surprise
surprise surprise idiot of the day
guessed clearly said I think that was
not invited to speak clearly said I
think that was not invited to speak at
one person clearly said I think that was
not invited to speak clearly said I
think that was not invited to speak
clearly said I think that was not
invited to speak they've actually got a
lead over it's happening it's happening
clearly said I think that was not
invited to speak
[Music]
so many segments about
[Music]
don't say I lose my little few
clearly said Alec I was not invited to
speak in this next clip you can clearly
see a woman telling me the reason I'm
being let in because I didn't come to a
security briefing because Tommy Robinson
tried to contact me and he couldn't get
through freepo saying he's categorically
not invited to speak now those posts
were removed from my facebook I didn't
remove them and admin remove them why I
don't know but they removed I wanted to
come up on the stage say things that
would really rile people up they could
have been a riot there could have been a
bloodbath it had been a flood bar it had
been a flood bar